and meanwhile you have nancy pelosi out
in full-scale defense for the biden
administration and it was all inevitable
now here's the thing either it was
inevitable
in which case they should have made
better plans or was not inevitable in
which case they got taken by surprise
they want to claim that it was both
inevitable and also they made excellent
plans which begs the question
what's going on over there if it was
inevitable and you made plans why do
things suck so bad
so they're just going to try to ram
through this cognitive dissonance these
mutually exclusive positions here's
nancy pelosi the speaker of the house
saying this was a tragic situation it
was tragic well how did that tragedy get
started and why is it tragic and what
what i've been told it's a great success
so what that what what is bad that is
happening there i don't know i just
don't know
this is
a a tragic situation i've been there not
eight or nine times africa we want to
make sure that there's a big bright
light shining
on afghanistan if they wish to
participate
uh globally in any way
[Music]
oh
so your threat is and the byte
administration's threat is that if
the taliban turn out to be bad
which i mean that would be weird if they
turned out to be super bad it would also
be really weird if it ended up being a
terror haven oh wait it already is
that'd be strange
so we'll shine our big bright light on
there and then if they do stuff we don't
like you know what we'll do
we'll send them mean letters you know
what we won't do put any boots on the
ground ever again you know what else we
won't do anything useful
what we definitely will do is threaten
them with economic sanctions because
people who have been living in caves for
the last 20 years or so what they are
most afraid of is losing the
conveniences of daily life
if there's one group of people who are
afraid of you cutting off their internet
access it is the taliban
those people cannot go without ebay
and they need their only fans and they
need it right to hell now and if you cut
that stuff off they will immediately
start talking about women women and
gender studies over at afghan university
okay don't worry the the democrats have
placed their ire in all the right places
you have ginsaki who's very angry at
eric prince for charging people to get
out of the country
meanwhile the u.s isn't getting people
out of the country at least not all of
them meanwhile nancy pelosi is very
angry who is she angry at she's angry
because there were two congress people
peter major from michigan and seth
moulton from massachusetts who went over
and did an
un
planned junket to afghanistan to see
what the situation is actually on the
ground over there now they did it with a
minimum footprint they did not take
seats away from people who needed to
leave the country
and they came back with some pretty
valuable information because we are
being lied to day by day by the biden
administration so it's pretty i mean you
have congress people do this sort of
stuff all the time right congress has an
oversight function of the executive
branch you have congress people who
routinely travel places to make sure
that things are happening is why you
have congress people travel down to the
border for example it's why you have
congress people travel over to europe to
make sure that what we say is happening
is actually happening at the white house
level nancy pelosi however is super mad
super angry at seth moulton and peter
major for going over to afghanistan why
well because they came back and they
told the truth about what they saw which
is that americans are going to be stuck
there after august 31st here's nancy
pelosi mustering all the ire she can in
her frail brain in order to uh in order
to get mad at the people who are truly
to blame these two congress people
when did you learn that congressman
bolton and congressman meyer traveled to
afghanistan and is that what prompted
your letter instructing members not to
travel to the region it's not just about
them going to afghanistan we're not even
going to the region because there's a
call on our resources diplomatically
political uh militarily and the rest
in the region as well so this this is
deadly serious we do not want members to
go
[Music]
it's deadly serious we don't want
members to go into war zones and we
certainly don't want them checking out
what's happening over there flashback
2007 u.s house of representatives
speaker nancy pelosi's decision to defy
the white house and meet syrian
president bashar al-assad steps up a tug
of war between democrats and president
george w bush over foreign policy
despite bush's admonitions the talks
were counterproductive and sent mixed
signals pelosi on wednesday sat down
with assad accused by washington of
backing terrorism and adding to middle
east instability newly empowered
democrats already doing battle with bush
over who is really the decider on iraq
policy are taking a more assertive role
on foreign policy
so um nancy pelosi you'll recall
actually went over to
syria and hung out with bashar assad who
was uh just preparing to kill you know
half a million syrian civilians and she
did that without the permission of the
white house
so she is a rich one to be talking about
how bad it is for congress people to
descend to a to an evacuation area to
survey the situation and then report
back accurately to the american people
it's all in this direction and here's
the thing
the bottom line here is that in the end
the biden administration knows this is a
debacle
they are hoping you forget about it in
the same way that americans forgot about
benghazi in the same way that americans
apparently have now forgotten about 9 11
they're hoping that americans just
forget about this by the time we hit
2022 it won't matter anymore you'll be
worried about your pocketbook you'll be
worried about what's going on with kovid
you won't be worried anymore about the
thousands of civilians trapped behind
enemy lines in kabul
it just won't be an issue for you the
only way by the way to make it a
non-issue for you is to just ignore
whatever happens over there so if
americans start being tortured and
killed don't look for the biden
administration to do anything more than
shoot a few missiles at camel asses the
same way that
that bill clinton did in the 1990s after
the bombing of our embassies in kenya
and tanzania
led him to basically blow up a supposed
chemical factory in sudan
but look for look for the same sort of
thing to happen from now on if americans
are mistreated if things get really
egregious in afghanistan
even if pictures emerge of the taliban
humiliating americans don't look for joe
biden to do anything there anymore he
has to justify the decision he is making
right now this is now the sunk cost and
joe biden is going to continue to engage
in the sunk cost fallacy
right the sun cost is getting out
that decision has to be made glorious by
joe biden the only way to make that
decision glorious is to suggest that
peace and at least stability now reign
in afghanistan and that there is no
ongoing threat from afghanistan so the
next few years are going to be about joe
biden downplaying any threat from
afghanistan
they're going to be about democrats
pretending that this is a massively
successful airlift they're going to be
about ignoring whatever comes next
afterward or
giving some mush mouth nonsense about
how we are negotiating and we're going
to get our people out eventually and
five years later the people will still
be there and they'll still be held
hostage by the taliban and will still be
covertly giving aid to the taliban and
they're hoping that you forget about all
this they're hoping that you forget
about the geopolitical consequences of
handing over afghanistan to the taliban
they're hoping you don't notice that
china feels emboldened and starts to go
after taiwan and starts to cut off
shipping lanes in the south china sea
they're hoping you don't notice that
russia is going to start getting pretty
feisty with latvia and estonia they're
because americans don't care about
foreign policy until they are forced to
care about foreign policy so the next
couple of years at a very minimum are
going to be about making you forget it's
all sleight of hand it'll make you
forget and the press presumably will aid
them in this task by moving on all they
have to do is delay all they have to do
in their own mind is get beyond august
31st because once they get past august
31st once they get past september 11th
americans will just go right back to
sleep so the only question is will we i
think there's a 50 50 shot we do maybe a
better than even shot that we do joe
biden is banking on the compliance and
complacency of the american people
and if that bet is correct frankly we
don't deserve to have the most powerful
country on planet earth we really don't
because that takes some upkeep joe biden
doesn't want to the upkeep he just wants
you to settle into the warm bath of
civilizational decay and slit your own
risks that is the goal here so will we
go along with it we're going to find out
in pretty short order because that's the
actual plan forget about the contingency
plans that's the actual
big p plan from joe biden
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video